an estimated 4 million people have fled
Venezuela is it harder here or in
Venezuela Wow beautiful chaos people are
dying for the basic things
[Music]
Venezuela should be an amazingly rich
country it's got the world's largest oil
reserves which means everyone should be
comfortable everyone should have a good
house to live in and everyone should
feel safe and not hungry actually quite
the opposite is happening Venezuela is
suffering so much not because of war but
because of social economic mismanagement
it was in the late 1990s that Hugo
Chavez came to power
extremely left-wing but also massively
charismatic he was this self-styled
champion of the people at that time oil
prices were climbing and he poured
billions of dollars into social welfare
programs and he also subsidized health
care and education so he was loved but
his strategy was unsustainable
so when he died in 2013 his chosen
successor nicolas maduro took over and
then things really started to unravel
there been a massive drop in oil prices
and basically the economy began to run
an empty runaway inflation huge
corruption alongside rampant
government spending and it led to mass
shortages of food and medical supplies
this country which should be rich beyond
all our imaginations has people
scrambling around in dust bins trying to
find food to eat
we knew that there might be problems
crossing into Canada
and we knew that there might be problems
in openly reporting generally there is a
level of suspicion towards foreign
journalists who they feel might come
from a part of the world which is not
sympathetic to their politics we didn't
feel terribly welcomed there keV was
filming quietly as we were walking from
Colombian checkpoint that's probably
about fifty meters or so no-man's land
as soon as you are in the Venezuelan
side get backs to you all the tension
you know
you start telling keV you know put the
camera away
be careful I was being what I thought
was discreet it's in turn that I wasn't
discreet at all
hear hear hear hear hear a whistle quite
loud some way behind me here here here
here that's we carried on walking and
keep hear the whistle that whistle got
louder pointed at me but I chose to
carry on walking hoping he wasn't
pointing at me one officer approaches
and says he cannot be shooting here she
he can get in trouble because this is a
protected area you cannot be doing that
I managed to switch the camera off but
he he wanted to have a look
luckily I'd filmed the flag and made out
that's almost filming and he seemed to
be satisfied with that you know having a
police officer whistling if you telling
me to stop filming it's not a great
start to the trip we were very much
guided by the Venezuelans that will rule
with I'll produce her Gustavo and the
two other people who helped us as well
they didn't want us to be openly filming
on the streets quite early on on the car
journey in I was filming out the window
and we came across a pretty ad-hoc
checkpoint and Gustavo panicked grabbed
the camera shutter it smile at the
camera too early to get lifted he didn't
want the guys on the check one seeing us
filming at all it's a quite
nerve-wracking moment they can see
you're your camera or they can force you
to delete the pictures or they can I
mean take the memory card out or destroy
your mobile phone what are the marked
differences you notice
on the other side for Columbia it is
absolutely bustling full of businesses
and people buying into selling and here
it seems a lot will run down for a start
and a lot a lot quieter you have to keep
on reminding yourself this is a country
which should be rich
there's not just one shelf that's empty
there's whole cabinets that are empty
the trouble is there are a very few of
the basic ingredients here for instance
if I wanted to make a cake there is no
milk there are no eggs there's no flour
there's no sugar and even the products
that are available are extremely
expensive for instance look at this
cream you'd have to work three weeks in
order to afford this now that's quite
difficult to get your head around the
amount of inflation there is it's
bonkers he's got to the point where the
physical money is just worthless you
could buy something and by the time
you've got your money out of your wallet
it's gone up three times this is a
hundred thousand boulevards the highest
note that they actually produced and
altogether this is something like 20
million still very much in circulation
it would actually buy you about four of
these so technically cheaper to use
these than this
people were literally throwing money
away
[Music]
we met one little boy called Juan Diego
he was on his own just living on the
streets where are your parents
so do you with who are you living with
you have friends do you have brothers
your sisters you have any relatives with
you
you are they get us home hey hey hey
but you mean again
many people in Venezuela are going
hungry I'm talking about people that
have their way of eating is eating in
the garbage
is pretty unimaginable people having to
scavenge through rubbish through
festering putrid rubbish just to survive
so how difficult is it when you've got
children that you also have to feed we
have to so much to feed our kids
there's no food that people can afford
[Music]
things have really spiraled out of
control
in some areas it's actually become
lawless the city of Maracaibo had been
ransacked it was like the OK Corral
gunfire all over the place they had to
have armed the Jalan T's guarding the
shops they've done a lot of damage we
went to one hotel and all five floors
had been stripped out every single room
has been torn to shreds every ceiling
has been brought down but even for large
on the walls as they've hacked their way
through here using machetes and guns
there are millions of dollars worth of
damage just in this hotel alone there
was real anger and violence there this
was a lot of people showing their
frustration and desperation and actually
taking the law into their own hands
[Music]
if the hospital was something else
it soon became clear that it was chaos
as soon as we went in the very first
thing the doctor said someone's just
died
I could hear a whine
and I could see the young lad bent over
and I'm sobbing
but you can see blood on the floor and
the trolley had be pushed through the
blood and it's pretty unpleasant it
really was quite a desperate situation
no it's her legs on a what looks like an
ironing board and this one woman who had
been there for some time already
she needed a metal pin still not good I
see and I don't see more when do you
think she will be able to have the
surgery maybe two months ring or three
months well the doctor was kind of like
well she's gonna be waiting for quite a
long time one of the young doctors was
taking us upstairs to show how a whole
floor had been cut off I've had to
completely close it
I've got no doctors no medicine to shut
down they are in such desperate times
some really basic stuff it really
shouldn't be an issue that is what are
you finding is the problem here
no you do not any angèle ordinarily
you'd have been able to save him is that
people are dying for the basic things it
feels horrible there was every example
of what could go wrong with human being
hospital and a lot of them were children
but knowing that they are suffering
because of a basic medicine supply that
you can buy over the contrary in some
different countries what happened to him
say I was story sort of epitomizes
everything that's going wrong in
Venezuela because he went in with a
fairly ordinary common problem he had
severe diarrhea and that had escalated
and being compounded by a whole series
of things that had gone wrong in the
hospital because it wasn't clean they
didn't have the medicines to give him
you know it's to pick up everything go
then he wasn't getting better he ended
up in with intensive care and only 20%
of the people in intensive care had
actually made it cult of intensive care
is knee hurting he was struggling to
breathe he wasn't able to talk he was
struggling just to move make small
gestures
we'd been filming too a few hours and
we'd heard so many stories horrible
heartbreaking stories and as the day
went on it was just getting worse and
worse
when is this when we first went in to
see Angela and her mother it was just
this pretty little girl lying in a bed
she was seven years old she had a brain
tumor and her mother was sort of
crouched over her and when she turned to
us her whole face was just filled with
unhappiness but how are you coping gave
me and she just looked in real pain
because of what she couldn't do to help
her daughter she know she had these big
eyes that seemed to be just we're
constantly welling up their voice was
breaking as she spoke to us and she
showed us pictures which she had on a
mobile phone look in which were just
taken a few months earlier when you look
at pictures like that
your heart must break
[Music]
and her daughter was dancing around and
taking part in some Joe she looks such a
happy healthy girl there and now just a
few months later she couldn't move she
looked in a bad state she knew what was
wrong with her daughter but she couldn't
help her and this was all because her
husband couldn't give her either
radiotherapy or chemotherapy nowhere in
Venezuela could
[Music]
an estimated 4 million people have fled
Venezuela when they said we have to go
to Venezuela to cover their Exodus
crisis and people getting out of the
country I said we have to go to the
border in Colombia it must be hard for
you watching your fellow countrymen and
women going through all of this it's not
fair that people have to leave their
families find a better future it's not
because you want because you must do it
unless you will you won't survive these
are desperate people who obviously feel
they haven't got any other choice today
the report que podrían oh yeah my mom
can be any tarp upon over 4 million and
on hundreds and hundreds of kilometers
by that stage and they still had further
to go and as she's limping and she's
coming just sandals she walked the whole
way in those sandals it is hard to see
people leave in their country for the
wrong reasons
but these are not people that are
willingly going away of the country
meaning they have no other choice but to
walk thousands of kilometers to the
border and then to another country
[Music]
[Applause]
there are tens of thousands of people
who are crossing over the water into
Colombia every day it was like the whole
town had moved to the border point the
Sun was beating down and people would
huddle around the trees and just any
shade they could get there were awful
lot of people sitting on pavements
suitcases children most of them looking
fairly fed up it's chaotic people have
been there for days sleeping on the
pavement how long has she been here for
Australia growing massive desperate
situation if you flew in the country
people don't necessarily want to talk
about it
how many moons they're proud we'd heard
that some of these people were being
helped by a Catholic Church it was like
feeding the 5,000 we found hiding at the
back of this big group was this fairly
young looking woman and she just seemed
to be surrounded by children all her
children were incredibly young the
oldest one she had was six so all the
youngest was something like eight months
she crossed the whole country with four
kids
she's quite embarrassed about being put
in that position that was the first time
she cried she wanted to take us back to
see where she was living now which she
said she'd managed to get a place in a
school the other children they were
young but they seemed to be older than
their years they weren't really as
inquisitive or running around they were
very grown-up
be the clearing plates or just helping
their mum they don't see being through
this quite a while they were infants but
they were little mini adults so we
followed her back which around the
corner and she'd managed to claim the
old school laboratory as her little room
for her and the children and I remember
when she walked in they all sort of
trotted after her Kent
described it as a load of little
ducklings walking after because they
just knew to follow it sort of magnified
their vulnerability and they were living
on the floor there was literally nothing
so I asked her about the bed and the
kids started making it if the bed was
just flat bits of cardboard which they
all put down they didn't seem like
children at that point it was really
quite sad is it harder here or in
Venezuela
[Music]
Wow and this is a woman who was living
destitute on the floor with their four
young children so that really says
something you see the situation she's
seen you can only pretend to imagine how
hard things are back in Venezuela these
are desperate people who are leaving in
such huge numbers it's on course to
become one of the biggest humanitarian
crises not just in that region but
perhaps in the world not a bomb has been
dropped
if you have a pulse you have hope so I
hope for a better Venezuela I say that I
hope he said he sees and I have that
disease so I went back to to spread the
disease
that's much a second
[Music]